gamma would never forget the horrific
site of
scp-5967 on the surface she kept her
nerve cool and collected her finger
ready to squeeze the trigger as her
weapons stayed trained on the entity but
deep down it turned her stomach after
all how is someone meant to react when
they see a thing like that a mess of
Flesh and eyeballs towering above them
staring back through more retinas than
any living creature has she did not yet
know it but she'd still be seeing that
disgusting pillar of musculature and
eyes in her nightmares for months to
come and still it wasn't even the worst
part of the incursion far worse than
seeing the five meter tall eyeball totem
watching it blink its many Lids at her
was witnessing what it had done to Alpha
only moments before gamma's commanding
officer had been in control of this
situation leading mobile task force
Lambda 5 into the metal lands of East
Rutherford New Jersey the mission should
have been a simple Smash and grab the
same old boring story their team had
lived through countless times before
pick up a high value Target the leader
of yet another cult practicing and
anomalous religion and bring him in for
questioning gamma never could have
expected that things would go this badly
the task force had arrived to discover
Caesar Winters the leader of a sect of
fifths operating in New Jersey when
Lambda 5 discovered him Winters and his
followers locals who were all members of
a group known as the commune were
standing in a circle around an instance
of
scp-5967 standing at around 5 meters in
height
scp-5967s were piles comprised of mostly
musculature and organs that resembled
eyeballs human eyeballs despite lacking
a mouth vocal cords or any other
conventional methods of speech these
pillars could still very much
communicate verbally although they had
little to say besides spouting phrases
and principles associated with the
fittest ideology almost immediately the
plan to capture Winters had gone awry it
was almost like he expected the
foundation to arrive like he knew they
were coming as the members of MTF Lambda
5 moved in keeping Winters in their
sights the anomalous cult leader somehow
turned the Gaze of
scp-5967 onto Alpha the team's field
commander ordered Delta to open fire
taking out Caesar Winters in a single
shot but only for a moment another of
the commune members kneeled over and
began convulsing a wound formed at the
person's neck and from it emerged Caesar
Winter's face it grew into a full-sized
head replacing that of the commune
member giving Winters a brand new body
in moments on Alpha's orders to stop
Winters from hopping to more bodies
gamma and the others in their team fired
on the the other cultists everyone was
terminated 15 seconds was all it took
then they moved towards
scp-5967 and everything went wrong the
body started to convulse violently as if
some unseen hand was shaking them around
like ragdolls gamma watched as they
began to levitate hoisted by their necks
and floating towards the mobile task
force not one of them knew what to do
keeping their rifles up and trained on
the corpses each one folded in on itself
becoming compressed masses of muscle
embedded with eyes that was when the
team lost Alpha something was happening
to their leader she had dropped her
weapon and Fallen to her knees
immediately gamma moved in to help her
commander trying to pull her back to her
feet but Alpha was resisting transfixed
by
scp-5967 it's
she is lost deep in the cosmos and is
angry with us for not helping her find
her way back she will kill us all lest
we line our brains and see her for who
she truly is gamma watched as her team
leaders Rush towards the pillar of eyes
and licked it the floating orbs of Flesh
and eyes that had once been people
suddenly hurtled towards the members of
MTF Lambda 5 at high speed gamma Dove
Clear at the vital moment performing a
tactical role and managing to narrowly
avoid being struck beta wasn't so lucky
ready to retaliate gamma raises a weapon
to fire the floating remains only to
hear Alpha ordering her to stop she had
stopped licking
scp-5967 but whatever influence had
compromised the mobile task force leader
hadn't relinquished its hold over her
she grinned unnervingly as her eyes
rolled back into her head don't you hear
her voice she is angry but I can save
you I can save us let me show you Alpha
said before charging at Gamma with her
arms outstretched in seconds before she
could defend against her commanding
officer gamma found herself pounced upon
by Alpha grabbing a nearby Rock Alpha
swung at her head and knocked gamma's
tactical helmet clean off pinning her
down possessed by some unknown anomalous
entity Alpha held open gamma's eyelids
and licked her eyeball gamma screamed in
horror as Alpha looked up to the sky and
yelled I can see you I could see
everything now the case of
scp-5967 is one of the stranger Tales
within the annals of the SCP
foundation's history their investigation
that led to the discovery of these five
foot tall pillars of eyes and muscle
originally began with a different
intention the commune had been making
waves in Lyndhurst New Jersey the kind
of waves that had caught the SCP
foundation's attention the two leaders
of this apparent cult were Salem steros
and Caesar Winters both of whom seemed
to be able to use
scp-5967s to take control of the local
residents mines anyone that they
affected could be controlled remotely by
either steros or Winters with a
seemingly unlimited range and no known
way of relinquishing their control over
an affected person amnestic treatments
hypnotherapy none of the foundation's
usual methods had worked undercover
Foundation operatives working secretly
within the Lindhurst Police Department
were the first to discover an instance
of scp-5967
right under their noses literally the
pillar of eyeballs seemed to have
sprouted up right in the middle of the
Lindhurst police station the foundation
sent in containment teams to secure the
area and administer amnestics to
Witnesses but just how were steros and
Winters causing these monstrous
musculature monoliths to appear well the
pair operated a radio show together
known as the reality sink the foundation
agents within Lindhurst had been unable
to track down exactly where they were
broadcasting from however after the
scp-5967 instance appeared within the
police station the answer seemed to
present itself during the building's
reconstruction tapes of their radio show
were recovered seeming to suggest that
the pair had been utilizing anomalous
means to broadcast the reality sync from
within the station itself while keeping
themselves concealed the reality sync
was a religious talk show specifically
focused on discussing elements of
fifthism with the audio and callers who
phoned into Winters and steros's hidden
Studio what exactly is fifthism well
there's no easy answer to that question
unfortunately other anomalous Cults and
religions at least have a core tenet or
belief at their Center sarcasism is the
worship of disease and Decay while
mechanites from the church of the broken
God venerate technology the beliefs of
the fifth church are a little more
interchangeable however they don't
really have any defined theology or
religious practices fifthism is often
more just a collection of recurring
ideas and motifs the number five stars
and the belief in an external Cosmic God
often a malicious one in fact if there
is a defining principle of fifthism it's
that it's an anomalous way of thinking
that it can't really be understood
practitioners of fifthism are concerned
primarily with transcending reality as
we perceive it they are highly
interested in entities and anomalies
that can warp and shape reality to the
extent of even being fearful of such
beings a lot of fifth is seek to not
only spread their influence to others
through any means necessary including
brainwashing but also hope to transcend
Humanity to a higher plane of reality
The Fifth Dimension there in theory a
person would cease to be a human being
and wouldn't even really be akin to a
god or powerful reality Bender instead
they would become something more vague a
concept unable to be fully defined or to
exist in reality completely fithus
followed this goal presumably with the
intention of saving humankind from
reality warping anomalies and they'll
use any infectious brainwashing Methods
at their disposal to bring as many
people as they can into their way of
thinking this brings us neatly back to
Caesar Winters and Salem steros Radio
Show the reality sink this was the
communes their particular sect of
fithism's way of spreading what they
refer to as the true
based on the various fragmented cassette
recordings of their show that the SCP
Foundation were able to recover both
steros and Winters believed in a many
armed goddess referring to it as only
she or her they encouraged their
listeners to pray to this entity and let
her know that they were loyal to her
during one of their recovered broadcasts
the pair of fithus hosts were even able
to prank call the SCP Foundation itself
one Junior researcher Jones was
contacted by the two men and ridiculed
for his association with the SCP
Foundation but after a few jokes at
Junior researcher Jones's expense steros
and Winters began to insidiously implant
ideas of fifthism in the researcher's
head they referred to this as giving
Jones the truth something they both
intended to do for all of their
listeners in order to save them when
asked what they really meant Winters and
steros made vague allusions to the truth
being an infinite knowledge that only
she could bestow Jones had no idea she
was meant to be our Guiding Light our
creator Salem described before adding
the very thoughts that should be
infiltrating your head right now it
seemed that through this call The Two
Hosts had managed to successfully embed
their fittest Concepts into the mind of
Junior researcher Jones and they weren't
about to stop there during another call
on their show both hosts spoke with a
Wallington New Jersey resident named
Wendy Ricefield who was already a
self-proclaimed fifthist steros and
Winters talked Wendy through a ritual to
learn the truth involving her drawing
sigils on the walls and floor of her
home and lighting candles the phone line
picked up wet squelching noises coming
from the other side the splintering of
wood and Wendy screaming for help as she
tried to run from her home only for
something to drag her back inside
eventually the foundation made the
executive decision to step in and deal
with the situation in New Jersey
directly steros and winters's operation
was getting out of hand more and more
people surrounding area were being
brainwashed into believing in fifthis
Concepts and compelled to complete
bizarre rituals sending a team in to
apprehend the cult leaders Foundation
Personnel discovered Salem steros and
numerous other members of the commune
they had gathered at an instance of
scp-5967 that had manifested in
Wallington the same place that Wendy
Ricefield had been from steros and his
fifth followers were discovered holding
hands and standing in a circle around
the anomalous pillar of eyeballs as well
as approaching it and licking
scp-5967 the members of the commune were
rounded up and most were sent to be kept
in isolation at site 9. however Salem
steros was brought to site-83 for
questioning Junior researcher Umar Hadid
conducted an interview as to the exact
nature of the Goddess her that steros
and Winters often referred to and the
anomalous rituals the pair had been
involved with Salem was less than
Cooperative he'd demanded to be set free
in the interest of saving people by
spreading the truth with Caesar however
he did reveal some key information about
her according to steros's claims she was
a goddess actively meddling with reality
and influencing human actions he told
Hadid that if he killed the junior
researcher right there it would be
because she willed it sometime before
both Salem and his cult co-leader Caesar
had been stargazing in the Meadowlands a
remote field in East Rutherford that's
when they had allegedly heard her voice
and being told the truth this reality
warping goddess was intending to return
home but that way was broken so
according to steros she needed their
help this was the reason he and Winters
began creating instances of
scp-5967 the eyeball pillars apparently
acted as beacons like a GPS signal
allowing her to come back the pair and
the rest of the commune were attempting
to prove their loyalty to her in the
hopes that they would potentially be
allowed to transcend reality in
accordance with the fifthis principle
Salem steros was remained into SCP
Foundation custody and kept attained in
a containment Suite surrounded by three
Scranton reality anchors shortly after
the members of MTF Lambda 5 were
dispatched heading to the location
steros had inadvertently revealed during
his interrogation their mission was to
arrest Caesar Winters who remained at
large after the leader of Lambda 5 was
compromised eventually gamma was able to
contact the foundation who sent a
containment team as backup they secured
the surviving MTF operative along with
the infected team leader Alpha and the
instance of
scp-5967 on the scene gamma was offered
medical treatment and presented with a
silver lion badge for her efforts in the
field along with a two-week vacation as
a reward that did little to stop the
nightmares though she wasn't the same
and neither was Alpha after two long
weeks of psychological screaming and no
further hostile or anomalous activity
Alpha was interviewed by Junior
researcher Hadid during their discussion
Alpha real name Cassandra Sandy denofsky
described that she could still hear
voices in her head rambling about the
truth fifthism and eyeballs amnestic
treatment wasn't helping suddenly
someone within the foundation played a
clip of Caesar Winter's voice over the
facility speakers taken from one of his
and steros's radio broadcasts it
triggered an instant paranoid reaction
from Sandy followed by her opening her
mouth and revealing something growing
inside another eyeball some kind of
post-hypnotic suggestion or other form
of brainwashing had affected her and she
began exhibiting anomalous Behavior tell
me Hadid are you a fitness now she asked
the junior researcher are you ready to
see the truth Hadid rushed out of the
room shutting the door behind him pacing
around the room Sandy started drawing
strange sigils of Unknown Origin on the
floor floor and walls fighting a candle
through anomalous means then there came
a bright flash of light as a four-legged
entity appeared and attacked Alpha the
two merged causing her body to change
until it was unrecognizable well it's
human anyway standing in the
interrogation room where Sandy had been
standing was a contorted mass of Flesh
and muscle with multiple eyeballs
staring out from it she had turned into
another instance of
scp-5967 they all had they were people
steros and Winters had made beacons out
of living people now check out scp-3760
like a doll's eyes and the iPods scp-131
for more